[Musique]
60 équipages deux hommes par moto ils se
relaieront toutes les heures ou 13h30
120 pilotes
cent vingt mille spectacles
c'est la première fois que je dorme et
disons que j'étais surprise par ce set
ahmad de moto ce tas de moto c'est
considérable sur la route c'était un peu
on vient tous les ans au bol depuis que
ça a pris deux ça fait quatre années
consécutives
j'ai une moto parce que je suis très
indépendante très individualiste et que
le véhicule qui me convient mieux
choisis mes passagers
habillée comme ça vient on a plus de
sexe moi cette moto tout mon salaire il
pense ne révision les chutes quand il y
en a en fait je suis jamais tombé encore
avec vous avez fait un choix entre les
filles et la moto et c'est moi en béton
ils ont moins de 20 ans pour la plupart
et ils sont venus avec tout leur
équipement pour passer la nuit sur le
circuit
[Musique]
si tout simplement pour enregistrer les
brûler des machines qui pour la gemme
bien ça
ensuite je pourrai les réécouter exemple
là vous avez une kawa c'est capital car
s'il est non
si tu l'entends
[Musique]
la manche
3 heures du matin les vainqueurs de
l'année dernière godier genoud sur la
kawasaki numéro un sont en tête
pratiquement depuis le départ
suivez bien en 23 secondes les mécanos
font le plein et georges odier passe le
guidon alain genoud la moyenne est
toujours supérieur à 130 kilomètres à
l'heure
on se détend on ne peut pas dormir on a
tout le temps l'esprit occupé et les
relais sont très courts
on se prépare à l'avancé on se prépare
pour 24 heures sans dormir
moi j'ai tendance à souffrir un peu du
coup la tête du marbre en arrière et mon
foyer me suis fracturé il ya trois mois
en arrière mais sinon ça va bien
[Musique]